الجماهير تشعل المدرجات في مباراه المغرب
واسبانيا اليوتيوبر الجزائري يعلق على
حادثه اعتداء سموالتو اردني يبيع كليته
لمريض عربي والقضاء يحاكم هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
نبدا من الحدث الكروي الابرز الذي يتابعه
الملايين وهو مباراه المغرب واسبانيا ضمن
منافسات الدوري ثمن النهائي حيث اشعلت
الجماهير المغربيه مدرجات استاد المدينه
التعليميه لدعم اسود الاطلس وفي هذه
اللحظات انتهى الوقت الاصلي للمباراه
بالتعادل السلبي وبدا المنتخبان اللعب في
الشوط الثاني الاضافي فيما شهدت 90 دقيقه
الماضيه فرصا عده لاسود الاطلس للتسجيل في
شباك المنتخب
وسط شهادات واسعه بادائهم وامال كبيره لدى
الجماهير تاهل المغرب للدور
ما في اخبار المونديال ايضا وبعد حادثه
اعتداء اللاعب السابق صموئيل ايتو على
اليوتيوبر الجزائري سعيد من عيوني خرج
الاخير في فيديو ليتحدث عن تفاصيل ما وقع
في استاد 974 وقال انه تشابك مع ايتو وشخص
كان برفقته مؤكدا ان اللاعب الكاميروني
حطم كاميرته الخاصه بعد ان قام بتصويره
وسؤاله عن ملابسات المباراه التي جرت بين
الجزائر والكاميرون في اطار تصفيه كاس
العالم والاتهامات للحكم قسما بالانحياز
فيها للجانب الكاميرا مشيرا الى ان
السلطات القطريه تحقق في الواقعه التي
لاقت انتشارا واسعا في السجن
نبقى باخبار المونديال حيث اعلنت اللجنه
العليا للمشاريع والارث في قطر ان مباراه
البرازيل وكوريا الجنوبيه التي حصلت امس
ضمن نهائيات كاس العالم كانت المباراه
الاخيره على ستاد
اربعه شرق الدوحه اللجنه اوضحت انه سيتم
تفكيك الملعب بالكامل والتبرع به لاحدى
الدول التي لم يتم الكشف عنها حتى الان
فيما يعد هذا الاستاذ الذي يحمل رقم مفتاح
الاتصال الدولي الخاص بدوله قطر يعد اول
ملعب قابل للتفكيك بالكامل في تاريخ كاس
العالم كما انه يتسع لاكثر من 40 الف
متفرج
في قضيه اثار جدلا واسعا في الاردن لجا
ابو مواطن الى بيع كليته مقابل 17 الف
دولار لشخص عربي يعيش في تركيا وذلك بسبب
الضائقه الماليه التي يمر بها لكن هذه
القضيه لم تمر مرور الكرام لدى القضاء
الاردنيه خشيه ان تتحول الى ظاهره اذ قررت
الهيئه القضائيه المختصه بقضايا الاشجار
بالبشر في الاردن الحكم غيابيا على شخص
يحمل جنسيه دوله عربيه في السجن لمده ثلاث
سنوات ونصف بعد ان اشتري الكليه من
المواطن بواسطه عربيه جنسيه ايضا وذلك بعد
ثبوت ارتكابه لجنايه التجاره بالبشر وفقا
لاحكام القانون الاردني
ما في خبرنا الاخير بدات ماكينه صرف الي
في بيع عملات ذهبيه عبر البطاقات المصرفيه
في مدينه حيدر اباد الهنديه صحيفه تاذي
اقامه
تعد الاولى من نوعها في العالم وليس فقط
في الهند مشيره الى ان الجهاز يحتوي على
خمسه كيلو جرامات من العملات الذهبيه ذات
العيار 24 قيراطا واوضحت انه يتيح شراء
العملات الذهبيه من نصف جرام الى 100 غرام
فيما يتم تحديث سعر الذهب بناء على تغيرات
سعره في بورصه لندن